made some changes behind me people like
us stars Chris Pine Elizabeth Banks
Olivia Wilde and Michelle Pfeiffer it's
a movie that probably no one's gonna see
but people should and this movie Chris
Pines father dies and he has to travel
to go see his mother he hasn't seen in a
really long time to go to the funeral he
had a bad father growing up but his
father leaves him 150 K and for a second
he's like hey my dad actually had bad
anymore but he finds a note instructing
him to take it to his sister who he
never knew he had Elizabeth Banks hi I'm
Frank his nose I don't understand you
don't have any sisters I dunno the whole
movie is them trying to get to know each
other however he is aware that she's his
sister is too afraid to tell her doesn't
really understand how to tell her and
she just thinks he's some guy so that
creates a little bit of attention now
this is a movie that's coming out in the
middle of summertime you know there's
all these big explosion blockbuster
movies that are coming out and some of
them have been really good it's so
different from the summer season it's a
really nice change of pace actually for
a really long time I keep saying Chris
Pine please leave play someone besides
Kirk I like you man
I like you but stop playing Kirk he
finally did it in this movie he plays a
actual character in this movie he did a
really good job too I was really
impressed with his work all the actors
around the board are really good even
this kid Elizabeth Banks has a kid okay
and he's basically the demon seed of Sid
from Toy Story I mean he has every
single problem eating pasta there he is
the problem child
this kid takes a brick of sodium throws
it in the pool at school to see it
explode I mean this kid does the kind of
stuff that when I was a kid I thought of
doing but never got around to there was
that one time in the girls locker room
Ruby won't talk about that if there is
one thing that movies have taught me
when you're dating a girl make sure you
don't have some illegitimate sister
somewhere you don't know about because
it just might be her you know in Return
of the Jedi when Luke tells Leia that
they're siblings and she just looks down
and shuddered about what happened on
Hoth hey brainy can I get you
something that they sell here I swear to
you on my life I will never hit on you
ever Wow thank you I'm sure that was
meant to reassure me but one of the
things I really liked about this movie
was the writing it was actually really
good dialogue I really like the way
these characters were written there were
a lots of conversations and movies just
a straight drama with some really
light-hearted comedy in it but this
movie was actually really well written
with a movie where it's just
conversation conversation conversation
it's really easy for it to get boring
and slow but the way these characters
had their conversations and the way the
actor played them they were interesting
with it was a good dialogue it was
actually realistic the stuff that they
said made sense and I enjoyed it it was
also really well directed to the
director had a really interesting style
when he approached this movie it wasn't
just let's frame these actors nicely and
have conversations he had scenes in the
movie that built up tension in certain
ways like when you have a script
sometimes it'll say like you know the
actor looks through this box of things
the director found ways to make those
scenes interesting and I was really
impressed by the way he did it now it's
kind of dumb about this movie is it
falls under that cliche where if a
character were to just say one sentence
the entire movie would be over and
everything would be resolved it would be
really awkward but there would be no
more movie and all this guy really has
to do is say you're my sister I'm your
brother but he just can't find it in
himself to figure out when to say that
and so the movie keeps going and it does
seem really unrealistic that a person
wouldn't say look we need to talk and
just say it at the same time though the
movie was able to realistically find
ways to make it seem like this makes
some sense that was really my main
problem with this movie I kept telling
to be like look dude just say it just
tell her now at the same time though it
did kind of add to the movie because it
gave the scenes an extra bit of tension
because he kept seeming like he was
about to you know and I like the kind of
twisted style the movie had because you
could tell she was falling for him and
that bothered him obviously because it's
his sister but she didn't know that and
so it created a bit of a drama that you
don't get in a lot of movies these days
all in all I was really surprised by
people like us there are problems with
the movie yeah it does fall under some
cliches of movies like this but in this
time of year it was just a nice change
of pace and I really enjoyed this movie
I'm gonna give it a B+ if you want to
check out people like us I suggest
trying to find it it is playing wide
it's not everywhere but I would really
suggest checking this out also right now
on the flick pick channel my butt
John and I when he was here we did this
Batman versus Indiana Jones video okay
it's very funny it's John's video i
really suggest checking it out if you
want to go see me as indiana jones
fighting him as batman go check it out
it's pretty funny and my question of you
guys is can you think of a movie that
you saw and you were like wow i really
didn't expect anything out of that movie
at all i just went in there and you know
what not bad until next time guys if you
liked this review you can subscribe to
my channel and get stuck my eyes